[Music]
a couple years ago i was asked by
hopefully future friends of the show
marcus mumford and carrie mulligan
to really
exceptional people uh they asked me to
emcee this charity event that they were
they were throwing for children in
conflict war child uk it's a great
organization and so i was so happy to to
be a part of it and to help and
i was a little bit nervous about
having the responsibility of emceeing an
event like that um especially since i
knew there were going to be some you
know really
entertaining people there and then i
found out john oliver was going to be
one of the presenters and a couple days
before the event i said well john
doesn't want to do that emcee it and and
they said well
maybe you would like co-em see it and um
and i s and i said yeah okay it seemed
like he was on board with that so when i
got there uh they asked me to they said
why don't you start and
and basically introduce john
which i did i had a few things planned
out and i got i got a couple chuckles
and then john came out
uh and really was the mc and
just destroyed i mean he
from the first line he had he was so fun
and you can only imagine
and i realized that destroyed in a good
way oh yeah yeah he killed and um this
year i was asked back to do it and uh
john was the full-time emcee they moved
me kind of toward the end and had me do
they said
are you are you okay just not doing
anything funny basically so i of course
was just happy to be there well it's
important to learn your place yes it's
and your lane so that you can stay in
[Music]
and you're listening to life is short
i'm your host justin long life could be
a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is my brother
christian who's also what would you say
your lane is well you're emceeing this
show that's true i'm capable of doing
some level if john oliver wanted to
host this show yeah well we would have
to step down yes it's john oliver oh
gladly i i'd and i'd listen
uh we shouldn't come like just start the
show shooting on it people are like it's
not [ __ ] on it it's it's admiring
how impressive yes yeah it's true he and
he really is god it's like if um
they asked
billy crystal to co-host the oscars with
you
yeah you'd be like why just maybe have
billy crystal do it i know
i know or like i was trying to think of
a football analogy when i because i was
going to
mention this before they said don't be
funny
avoid any kind of humor because they put
me in a more serious part of the evening
because the evening is
the whole thing is like
is a very serious thing it's about um
rehabilitating these kids from conflict
zones and who have seen horrible things
and there was an incredible speaker who
was a former child soldier in sierra
leone this guy mohamed mohamed sidibe
who's now like an oppressive lawyer at
this huge law firm but so it it is like
it's weird it's like you have to kind of
toe the line between acknowledging this
very serious thing
but in a lighthearted way it's strange
because i think i think you're obviously
capable of being a serious person and
you have serious elements to your
personality but when i think of your
lane in terms of
being a presenter of any sort i wouldn't
think your lane would be introducing
something more serious i know and i
wasn't all that comfortable doing it i
was happy to do it because it was i was
happy to be a part of this thing but
yeah it felt a little
and then you feel like you're being
heavy and the whole thing is heavy
and
i don't know it just wasn't it's not
worth comfortable well why are we
talking about um seeing things well
because our guests today play thank you
for asking i was just curious you were
uh you were that was an mc move
you know to like i you're getting a
background maybe that's my lane yeah
your lane is to get me when i go out of
my lane
no no that's different i think i'd be a
good mc you would be you'd you control
the i don't know if i'd be a funny mc
but i think i would be good at like
you know keeping the ball well in the
air that's another thing that john
keeping things moving he did that very
well too he was like because you really
have to you know and now introducing he
did a lot of that he he kept it uh the
ball in the air in such a great way such
efficient yeah he would be great at
hosting this show
um but yeah you're right why are we
talking about mcs
our guest today played
i think one of the most famous emcee
characters in history in a in a little
show called cabaret
our guest today i went off mike for that
that wasn't a good move for an emcee our
guest today is
our guest today is the incredible alan
[ __ ]
alan [ __ ] what did i say you screamed
it oh yeah so you did it in more see
that would be your
lane no more like let's let's be a
little bit more respectful
that's what it's let's not you're not
introducing hulk hogan
ladies and gentlemen
i know yeah ellen cummings well alan
also has like a um
i i don't think he would have minded
that like he's got like a body playful
yeah like let's let's be
you know goofy
would you say like remember we used to
use that word
ribbled ribbled yeah ribbled he was can
you describe him as ribbled well i don't
really know for sure because i haven't
heard from him oh yeah that's right and
but well we're about to i'm excited so
why don't we just get to that well if
you play a little context maybe a little
more context i don't mean to mcsplain
you
but um you should but in addition to
playing the mc in
the in cabaret on broadway and winning a
tony award for it it's it's it's like
one of the most legendary broadway
performances of all time how many times
three different times i did it twice but
maybe three he did it in the west end
it's it's a it's like an iconic
performance yeah alan [ __ ] playing
the mc on broadway but it is but he's
done so many other great things and now
he has a great book out yes it's called
baggage uh i really loved it i can't
recommend it enough it's um he's just
very forthcoming and honest and very
funny he's he's a great writer too
you're about to hear from him how um how
eloquent he is and what a great voice so
if you've got a chance listen on listen
to it on on audible or some you know not
an ad but he reads it
oh he sure oh wow i bet that's
is that how you consumed the book no
i cause i read it before when it was
just in um
a pdf form because i read it before it
before it came out oh cool yeah i got
there lucky yeah he had a little inside
track but um he it is it's
really infectious it's a page turner
that's quite a page turner and um again
he's he's like so
funny and eloquent but like also very
honest um about his father the the very
turbulent relationship he had with his
father and and coming to terms with that
and processing it and um
and moving forward which he seems to
have done in a really admirable way uh i
i just
i loved it so uh and so a lot of the
conversation is about that um but it
helps us talk about his life because of
course it's a memoir so uh hopefully you
guys all enjoy this conversation with a
very cheeky very talented
lovely legendary legend iconic
alan [ __ ]
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
i like that sound oh
am i forcing my voice down now because
i'm so in love with the richness of it
your mellitus tones
it's uh is it too mellifluous
yes yes
let's go take a bite of a sandwich yes
okay so alan is eating a sandwich i'm
just describing to our listeners it is
it looks to be a baguette maybe some
lettuce a vegan turkey club so alan
while he's eating his vegan turkey
sandwich uh i have to
just tell him and all of you listening
how much i loved this book i uh there i
i'm looking out my if you see me looking
down it's just that i'm referencing all
of these parts that i copied and pasted
that um i am going to try to apply to my
own life there's so much of your
insights into relationships and
uh some of it is specific to acting and
uh certainly the theater but so much of
it were just these universal truths that
that i think a lot of people will find
valuable i loved it and i want to
ask you some specific things about it
but
it just generally alan um that's so nice
oh i i truly um did you talk about being
a vegan in the no
no
i wasn't vegan until when the book ends
it ends in 2007. okay so i wasn't vegan
then i was vegetarian i suppose but yeah
no i didn't talk about that then well
you were very sensitive to the plight of
um one particular animal uh a great
story that i i want to ask you about the
gold thing the goldfish yes it was very
sweet how concerned you were with the
safety of this goldfish
um but but really but also the
chimpanzee that you worked with oh oh
you know it's so awful because there's
been a development tonka so i made this
film in 1997
and there was these chimps in it and i
was the chimp looker after and that's my
character i was i was rene russo's
assistant and she had a gorilla and that
wasn't a real gorilla it was an
animatronic
thing and
there was four chimps
in this in the actual film and there was
one chimp called in real life he was
called tonka
and he played joe's so anyway there was
a you know my character and he were
great friends and he we got on really
well i mean i loved working with these
gyms just having chimps
you know climb over you it was so great
and i was prepared i was in the mid
towards the end of shooting that film
romeo michelle's high school reunion i
had to go out to
also it was in l.a you know both films
and i had to go out to this place in the
desert where the chimps um lived and
where they were training but on the way
to ojai
and that's where they had their sort of
where they lived and i would go out
there and you know sort of train with
the chimps which just sort of meant them
getting used to me and that's
sniffing you and yeah all that and so
then and then we made the film and
during the film he got really we got
really attached he got really jealous of
like the makeup ladies touching me
and he would he would get really in the
morning like i would see him sitting on
his little chair in the trainer there to
maintain eye contact all the time and
then he the trainer would see me and he
would say okay and tonka would run
across the set and leap into my arms
it was magical and then
it was so nice and then after the
film the next year i came back to do the
press thing and they i thought i was
going to you know be reunited with him
and he he did i've got actually here's
the painting that i talked about let's
see that oh yeah yeah ellen's showing me
a wall print that's his hand but he did
that painting this is a painting by a
chimp i'm sure oh my god and that was
sent to me in um
budapest because the next film i made
was this really dark film in budapest i
was really depressed and so my friend
caroline who directed the film that
tonka was in sent me as a sort of you
know get picked me up thing was this
painting by this chimp anyway
basically uh the next year they wouldn't
let me see him because he was now six
and was now sexually aggressive and they
were basically worried if he saw me
he would um perform a sex act on me
right a non-consensual one obviously a
non-consensual one yeah um and so
uh
anyway and then then he was were they
specific about what sex act he would do
or they it was anybody's guess at that
point i mean i had my own idea of what i
thought it was going to be
yeah but they let me it's the thing is
they let me groom they let him groom me
he wants to groom me all the time that's
right and and the thing is the trainers
wouldn't and like he would try to play
with me he basically he thought i was
another chimp because it would grow
dangerous alan is that why the dreams
yeah well because if they do aggressive
play that's
that's fine but it's there they're
stronger than us and so he could hurt me
and but the fact he wanted to
and that he wanted to groom me meant
that he thought i was another chimp and
i just thought that was the most the
biggest compliment i'd ever had oh yeah
so on the last day of the film they let
him groom me a bit and so that when they
groom you chimps they make let's go
noise
thanks and then they start you know they
pick your hair and they're looking under
my armpits and he was you know he wanted
to go further down they were like no
am i late
because you detail all this in the book
it's very funny the way you talk about
it but it's also i was i was so curious
what that actually felt like
we talked to
dr jane goodall i was lucky enough to
talk up to her on this show and um she
of course has a much richer richer
background than either of us could ever
hope so i wondering somebody that's a
little closer to myself in terms of
their experience with chimps
what that felt like what what it to a
layman uh it feels like it felt really
lovely because i knew he really wanted
to do and he was getting to do something
he'd wanted to do did you feel bad that
there weren't i wondered this that that
you didn't have any parasites i imagine
you he didn't find anything
no no i i i didn't think of that i
should have popped a few in perhaps but
he
he now he was
looking through my head and everything
and loved it was fascinating with my
legs and you know armpits was fine and i
just
but then it became like oh this is not
this is
going over stepping over the line here
yeah and he wanted to go down you know
into my pubes and stuff and and of
course we were then to let him do that
um but then i felt bad for him because
oh that's a shame because he's you know
he's sort of coitus interrupt us a bit
you know yeah and he was probably
thinking well why interrupt that i mean
why yeah i mean
the whole thing was
it was
but anyway i guess that's the whole
thing and microcosm of dealing with wild
animals in a sort of you know
domesticated setting that was sort of
it's right there but so then i basically
what happened was i thought he
they told me he was retired and had gone
to live in
palm springs
so i you know i always think of palm
springs as gay people and old people and
now i think i think gay people old
people and um
and also
my
terms yes my my joke and the thing is
because you know i presumed it tonka was
if not if it was not gay then he was
certainly bi-curious george
it's such a good joke it's such a good
joke alan that i wondered if the whole
story had been set up just for that line
no that's at all i didn't even think of
that until i was writing the thing oh
really but then anyway so then is that
one of those lines while you're writing
that you just think oh
he does it
hilarious yes by curious george thank
you george uh anyway so um except
there's a
there's actually a song there's a group
called the wet spots have you ever heard
of them no they're great you should look
them up they're hilarious from vancouver
and they're kind of like a little
couple
uh man and woman couple and they sing
these really hilarious songs because um
and they're really kind of you know
loungy and then you listen to the lyrics
you're like what and there's one called
bicurious george and there's also one
called um
do you take it in the ass that's one of
the other ones too it's just hilarious
yeah like the moldy peaches
do you take it in the ass
like that anyway so
then i discovered years and years later
peter came to me because i've done
things with peter and they came to him
basically said we found tonka in this
awful
yeah
caught laughing they called a sanction
he was in in missouri and he was inside
in a cage inside he didn't get
socialized with other animals he was
like in his own poop and there was all
these and basically they so they it was
a long long drawn-out process with
lawyers i think they got
there was 11
chimps in this thing they got like seven
of them out
too and went to this place in florida
where they have these little they make
these little islands yeah and then they
re-socialize them and then so they get
to run free on these islands anyway the
last thing that happened was that they
did get the remaining ones out but they
said that tonka would died
and i know but actually peter are not
sure that he has died they think they
they think he the lady has hidden him
somewhere and that he's actually still
alive because there was no kind of
evidence of his body or oh god and so
they think maybe that he's somewhere on
his own and this kind of
slightly hordy person has i don't know
so
last i heard they were trying to they
were getting for the courts to get a
subpoena to try and find it if they
could investigate to see whether it was
oh it's just awful though
oh i think
i was curious what had happened um
because i love that part of the i mean
so it's one of so many great stories
that you tell about about um
you know working with some of these act
i mean it was an actor that you worked
with uh
yes yes
but but also i i totally understood that
feeling of you you talk about the
connection with this animal and it and
it makes sense that you have there are
other parallels in your book that
my father was i i was i'm fortunate to
have a very wonderful father but um
i i have a similar people-pleasing
instinct that that
new detail uh in your book something
that that you've kind of struggled with
um yeah yeah and i i always wonder if my
connection with animals is is one that
is uh exists because it's there's such a
purity to a connection like that you
know there is
a a true unconditionality
um absolutely
it's so funny actually my um
my dogs um i've got these we have these
two dogs now but we had two
the four uh who died um called honey and
leon and we wrote my husband as an
illustrator
and he um i'm trying to save a picture
of my oh god here's a huge picture honey
can you see that one on the wall there
oh yeah huge honey
it was like what is that a costume it's
like a curly shepherd mix yeah and then
leon was a chihuahua and um oh you know
it's nice to see honey because you do
talk about honey quite a bit in the park
i do in the book i can't remember but
then we so we've so we wrote these two
kids books uh grant drew them and i
wrote them called the adventures of
honey and leon and now we've we've sold
the thing to cartoon network to make
into wow and it's so funny we're so sort
of
because i started thinking you know
writers
you you do think and then somebody else
buys it and you kind of you know you're
involved but in some way you let it go
sure um but we are very
i can tell overly
involved and protective because it's our
dogs yeah sure and so you have this very
emotional attachment to it so whoever is
going to
excuse me be the person who is the
showrunner we we need to feel like
they're oh taking care of the spirit
you're the you're those custodians of
legacy
yeah so that's that's something i've
just realized recently in the process of
finding someone to
to to to herald the new adventures of
our
now would you voice because i know you
know you're also talking about this how
many voices how many like specifically
animals you've voiced in your career
alan would you like voice either honey
i do well in a and i do in the
we did a an e audio book of the first
one
because
i do both i did both honey and leon what
do they sound like do you because i
often wonder this about my pets like i i
like to try to humanize them and give
them at that they're usually kind of
like slightly
slightly like this i like to i don't
know why dogs sound like that to me
that's so funny because
right now we have jerry and lala and
jerry
when we got him they said he was my kill
shelter in uh tennessee so we made him a
rather southern gentleman who saw the
talks like there and hi everybody you
know and then we discovered that we a
couple weeks later we went back to fill
in some forms or something and they were
like oh no he wasn't from tennessee he
was from the bronx
but we'd already given him his he had
already given him his name so sometimes
he says things like well you know uh
when i was uh
that used to happen to me a lot in the
bronx i mean in tennessee that's funny
and then lala is um she's a she's a
collie uh spaniel mix and she was a
street dog in costa rica so she talks
like these uh everybody
stop eat daddy stop eat
and um so honey and leon honey was like
a collie shepherd
and she was like this actress where
again the book she's sort of like this
um drama queen
so she was kind of this posh english oh
dab stop it that's awful
hello everybody let's talk about that
and then leon was this little uh he
talked like um what's that mike was
hello everybody he had a sort of a widow
oh a little elma fudd a way to well my
fun that's it yes hello
[Music]
alan that wow that also really showcases
your vocal range which
um i love that in the book too where you
talk about
having to lose that uh the the process
through which you lost that and and
the the political necessity to lose that
and uh
how how you retained it for some of your
performances and i specifically with
hamlet how you you kept your scottish
accent and how
you know how it caused kind of a stir it
was mentioned in every review of the
performance yeah i found that
fascinating it is fascinating and i
think i was trying to sort of because i
i find that
american people um
are not so
aware of the kind of
sort of political and class connotations
of between scotland and england right
and you know one of the things that i
found that when i first moved to new
york
was that and why i guess i was so so
loved it here
well one of the reasons is that many of
the things that i was celebrated for
when i first came to new york to do
cabernet on broadway was like no my
difference my scottish is my voice
the way i thought about things my you
know
my kind of
my values um
even even even sort of my you know
sexuality and stuff like
which were all things that the voice and
the accent and the values were all
things that when i was living in london
because i was scottish were sort of
subliminally
um and not so subliminally kind of you
know negatives i was i was reminded of
them in a negative way whereas here i
was reminded of them in a very positive
way it's interesting yeah and it's
partly to do with the so you know it's a
sort of a
slightly a class thing but anyway so in
the book i talk about
you know this thing of finding your
voice both as a person and as an actor
it's very important and being what is
your authentic self and actually it was
very confusing to me growing up because
i saw that
people who were scottish
when they reached a certain level of
success and they moved away they would
kind of lose their scottishness
um and and and and then when i went to
drama school
i never ever um
hardly ever anybody spoke in my own
voice this voice
um
and so
i it took me a long time to
so
because because you know and then of
course when i left when i did this you
know found that it was great to speak in
my own voice and and especially for
things like shakespearean stuff like
that how it really helped yes the
lateralness of you talk about the
gutturalness of the scottish but i bet
it did but was that a was that a
difficult like for hamlet for example
when you when you did the uh
warehouse was that a difficult choice
was that something that people
tried to dissuade you from doing people
didn't no because like the director
who's called stephen unwin he
i
he i'd worked with him
before and uh so no it was always going
to be that and i
and i'd said how much i enjoyed doing
shakespeare and so no people didn't try
to dissuade me from it
but people it was it was a huge thing
like it's always a bit huge if you're
playing
hamlet in london you know it's a it's a
big it's sort of the big
classical part for a young actor so
there's always a
and you're always compared to other
people and it's almost right so suddenly
i come along cookie scottish boy played
it in a very different way i played it
as as you know someone i played it like
how i thought
in a sort of realistic naturalistic way
a guy whose dad had died he basically
came back to this
really dysfunctional family situation he
wanted to be back at college with his
friends
his
girlfriend dumps him his friend he
realizes friends of who have come back
they've portrayed him and then also
there's this ghost of his dad appears
asking him to kill his uncle you know
there's a lot going on
so but basically drama
big drama but basically essentially he
was someone who was a student who wanted
to be back at college
and so that was how i thought about it
so i
and i and i was very emotional in it
yeah very weepy in it as well
a lot yes
i discovered what the word lacrimos
meant when it was mentioned so many
times in reviews it means
in a pejorative way
um
slightly but uh
but um but no i mean it was quite sort
of you know well it was people liked it
but they all mentioned this thing about
my voice my accent and about my
scottishness and about this choice i had
to play and i thought gosh it's so
interesting you know that
i always make a joke that everyone
thinks jesus
is american because whenever we see
jesus he has an american accent right
and it's like hamlet
even though he's danish right danish
prince yeah he must sound english
i know well the illusion
the illusion is to the i mean it's an
inherently insulting
uh implication that that they are scots
are
unintelligent and unintelligible and
yeah
that must have well that was a big thing
is there's a there's a there was a thing
in a
a newspaper that said um there should be
a sign
outside the dharma warehouse to say that
um
you know the audience should be warned
they might not understand all of all of
the play because uh hamlet has been
played with a scottish accent and had a
cartoon
of me uh with the skull but you know the
last periodic and it said alas per yaric
see you jimmy and cu jimmy is i think
it's a sort of
a jokey thing it's a sort of a glasgow
thing you go see you jimmy like look at
you know
cu means like
hey you over there uh
uh and but it's got a kind of a thing
connected with violence it's like it's
sort of a thing of uh kind of you know
yobe
neddy violent person would say see you
jimmy so they was they were kind of
making it
that i was unintelligible
that i was sort of violent i was kind of
a criminal yeah and this was all and at
the time what's really interesting is at
the time i didn't really i said i was
like oh god you know how predictable but
it wasn't something i thought how
outrageous how to yes
you know like 20 a couple of years ago
so many 20 25 years later
there was a production um in scotland of
uh of pier gint
and the with scottish people uh you know
they were it was actually set it was
david haye who's not scottish but he'd
set it in scotland and this critic said
that when somebody came on he was
english it was so nice when blabla
came on stage to get away from those uh
grating scottish accents
and of course when that happened
everyone was like [ __ ] you yeah mr
little critic and it was a big outcry
about the racism of that i'm sure
and i actually thought how good now
people are actually speaking out about
it and exactly is actually i think and i
realized in that
with hamlet
it wasn't that i just i didn't i didn't
feel
it wasn't i felt cowed it was just it
was so normal to me yeah that's what
people thought and that's what i said
and that's how i
felt
but i was determined to kind of i liked
it and i was determined to find my own
voice and so it's it's interesting so
it's a part of the book a chapter called
authenticity and i talk about you know
finding your voice in all sorts of ways
and and the whole scottish thing
of being you know feeling
sometimes you need to go away from where
you're from to understand who you are
and what
parts of you are formed by where you're
from and i think that's definitely true
of me
and and i'm so glad you were able to
have that moment with you talk about
billy connolly and that he was one of
the few who held on to who retained his
scottish ism and uh that you were able
to have that moment it's a really
beautiful story um
that i won't
be people just should read the book and
we'll talk
to continue to to talk about how great
the book is but um i love that part of
it and i also it's funny how because i
to me i it's easy for me to divorce
myself from any of the political
implications of the accent and and
scottish versus versus um the rest of
the united kingdom but but i
i just think it's a it's a wonderful
accent to hear i i just love
the sounds of it the tones and um i i
dated somebody from scotland for a
couple years and i used to love and all
her friends had these great
thick uh
they also have these great uh you
mentioned one about jimmy that has
implications to to violence so it's not
as
in that context it's not it's not
necessarily a good thing but she had
some great ones i remember um
when they get embarrassed their sheep
she would say oh that's it's quite a
beamer that's a beamer i've got a beamer
yeah yeah did you know that one i
totally means you get you're blushing
yeah
pure beaming
yeah
but it was great because you could say
in front of people who were who were the
source of the embarrassment who were
making you who were just like yeah you
know they were she was in a band so
sometimes people would come up and be
and say uh
oh and just embarrass
them you know and so she would she was
like it's a real beamer so you could
actually say it in front of me i love
that yes
such great especially from the west
coast it's going to such great
great sayings i love like um
what are some of my favorites like uh
oh biofin is really good do you remember
another one biofuel means like when
somebody's disgusting oh biofin and i
still say things like ah you know what
oh my my assistant matt he
there's a thing where i say oh that
palaver
oh yes
you'd say lava is good and he always
says palova no pavlova he gets it like
you know like the valley dancer and uh
and uh scanner there's a really good one
scanner i'm fair skunner it's like
you're just like frustrated
scanner
egypt uh glitch blanket that's like
you know when i did the smurfs i was uh
the scottish
gutsy smurf and the smurfs right
when i first uh
was doing it they said you know we'd
love to um
you know for you to love gutsy to be
authentic and like maybe some of some
scottish words you'd like to
so i am what was i i i brought back to
the lexicon
was it scannered
no i don't think i can't remember what
it was now hang on there's a there's a
there was a there's a word that gutsy
smurf kept saying
got c smurf uh this is
i'm gonna google gutsy smurf no what did
i say
i didn't know there was a gutsy smurf
gutsy smartphone that was me
gutsy smith toy top international yes
i'm a shaman too as well that's my you
know there's you know you do these
things i think it was great maybe it was
glacier
i like it maybe it was glacier that i
kind of he kept saying
let's see um
but it was such fun to be able to say
words and actually a lot of those
scottish words they don't people don't
really know what they mean when they sin
but actually so if they're they're
onomatopoeic they really sound like what
they're supposed to be you know i think
that's yes i love that about it and i
love
i love like the sayings things like
cheap as chips it's a really great yes
cheapest chips
shape is chips i love them i to me see
it's such a fun
accent to hear it's so i that was a bit
of a surprise that it had those kind of
uh implications for for other people
there was anything but of course you
know
i i wasn't considering the history of um
yeah
well it's just a sort of thing like you
know that's it's a sort of uh
it's fascinating that you know and of
course you get in such trouble for
saying things but there's there's some
i i felt not so subliminal racism uh
against scottish people it's against
irish people you know there used to be
signs yes
irish people have it really bad in
london but it used to be science saying
no no blacks no dogs no irish outside
pubs in london relatively in the last 30
40 years oh that was yeah
and so and i definitely felt and it was
interesting when i lived in london when
i first moved there i i i realized you
know i used to have a sort of a posse of
scottish people scottish actors we
always used to sort of you know meet and
uh huddle together and i think it was
actually it was it was a necessary thing
to do because you did feel a little
like outsiders and then the way that i
don't i don't sort of do that in in new
york i've never done that
so it's
interesting sorry has that made you feel
closer to people who um other
marginalized groups who have struggled
because you you've been so on the
forefront your activism has uh reached
many different groups i mean i i do
understand
what it is like to be
derided for for who you are yeah yeah in
various ways you know or to have or to
and or to not be equal
i do i mean and obviously not in the way
that and that some sections of our
society do like people of color of
course but i understand when people
make decisions about you about your
education about your intelligence about
your worth
purely because of where you're from and
how you sound and things like that so i
i that's been something that was i grew
up with and i've
it's a sort of isn't ingrained in my
culture and i think actually
scotland is in a very different place
nowadays because it actually is much
more uh
it's not quite independent yet but it's
much more
confident in itself and i think that
i've i've grown up
in a time when my country has actually
changed quite radically in terms of how
it's views itself and how it's
you know um
you know that way when you know when you
go to different cities in the world
and some cities are kind of needy they
need to know that you like them the
people there keep asking you if you're
having a good time
right you know there's some cities like
that and there's other cities
that don't give a [ __ ] what you think
they actually hope you have a good time
they're not mean but you can tell that
their value their self value does not
depend upon your
values that's true austin used to be
like that i think um yeah whereas like
you know and i i i go to bank i've made
a lot of films and things in vancouver
and i find that in vancouver people are
very you know do you like vancouver you
know they're very they want your
approbation yeah that's true so
interesting and you think my god this is
a fantastic place shut up
it is why and why are you doubting it
why are you so insecure as a city
[Music]
are you having trouble sleeping i was
not anymore right because of what plus
cbd i've been using these plus cbd sleep
gummies daily and i've been getting such
great rest and i've been waking up
feeling focused and refreshed yeah me
too there's no feeling of like
grogginess or like haziness the next
morning which you know i've taken over
the counter stuff and
occasionally i'll if i really need to
sleep you know if i'm jet lagged or
whatever i'll take something more heavy
duty but um these i haven't needed
anything else these are all natural
formulated by a team of medical experts
and doctors plus cbd sleep gummies taste
great they really do watermelon peach
i've had and are made with award-winning
cbd combined with melatonin magnolia
bark and lemon balm calm gummies are
nice during the day if you're feeling a
little overwhelmed if you want to calm
down a little bit the calm gummies are
great sleep gummies are great at night
if you just need a little positive push
during the day and if you want a fun
combination the reserve collection
mummies which have 25 milligrams of cbd
and 2.5 milligrams of thc uh that's what
we had last night yeah those are the
best they really do
and it's it's a small for me at least
it's a it's a low enough
amount of thc that's that i feel
comfortable and fun and like upbeat and
happy without getting too weird no yeah
it's it's just enough it's just enough
it's just the right amount yes a little
a little something something sleep
better tonight by visiting
pluscbdoil.com
and enter promo code long for forty
percent off your order that's code long
at plus cbd oil dot com for forty
percent off hey life is short listeners
business wars is a podcast from
wondering that brings you the full
stories behind some of the biggest
business battles in history in their new
season you'll hear about the fight
between espn vs fox sports to dominate
the sports television industry espn is
the american cable network that plays
the trail for around-the-clock sports
coverage athletes even change the way
they play just to get on sportscenter's
nightly highlight reels but right around
the corner rupert murdoch's fox sports
channel started gaining on espn in the
us the sports tv business is worth more
than 12 billion dollars the question is
who will come out on top fox sports or
espn listen to business wars espn versus
fox sports on apple podcast amazon music
or you can listen one week early and add
free by joining wondering plus in the
wondery app
hello hello again
[Music]
you have been all over i mean the truth
is like and you talk uh about you know
about your travels in the book and and
um i i'm curious having
having gleaned some of that
where you are now i mean where your
heart lies like
where do you feel most at home
i feel in in the way that i
compartmentalize
my
life in you know i'm very i'm have a lot
of different things going on
and i but i'm very focused in what i'm
doing and i'm equally as focused and
having fun and letting go as i am with
doing this today or you know what i want
to do next and
i'm very i just
i love how you talk about that how
you're there there's something you're
like responsible in your abandon
yes yes i love how you talk about that i
love because you've always whenever i've
been around you you've
you've just been such a light such a
buoyant
spirit
um truly always and never from uh always
from a good place you know some people
you find they're like that because it's
driven by this compulsion to be liked or
driven by drugs or whatever it is
there's like
you know a need to keep the night going
but you've always had this real light
and to to the point where i was really
like
stunned by
some of the tragic elements of your
upbringing and your relationship with
your father and
i'm
you say in your book after the
confrontation with your father that you
never had fear after that you never yeah
i think it's amazing to me well i mean i
think you know i i
i genuinely feel
that
the worst things that could happen to me
have already happened yeah
and i mean i suppose if i got my head
chopped off and tortured that would be
terrible but do you know what i mean in
terms of like what it's like if you get
your head chopped off then tortured it
wouldn't matter yes actually yeah
but i so i feel in a funny sort of way
and you know facing your like when i
went to my brother and i went to
confront my father
about the fact about the he was very you
know i think my father was
and i write that in my first meme where
i talk about this a lot it's not my
father but he
was i think mentally ill and was very
violent and very cruel and very
you know abusive very abusive and so
eventually we
went and confronted i
the start of this book i talk about how
suddenly all those memories when i was
about when i was trying to be a father
myself
all kind of came back to me i'd
suppressed all these memories and i
think actually it's a you know an
amazing thing that your brain
yeah does that because you're too young
to actually process the magnitude and
the horror of what's happening to you
yeah so you just put it away and you get
on with your life and i didn't i
seriously did not remember i mean i
didn't i knew he was
had hit me and i knew he was you know i
don't but the actual specificity of it
and the amount of it and
i just and they all came flooding back
when i was about to how did it ellen how
how did that come back i mean was it
ruth sir
yes
as well i mean i said what happened was
i was kind of started to get very i was
trying to be a father
i was mad as we were trying to have kids
and
i started to feel really weird i started
to feel you know i was thinking about
you know what kind of father am i going
to be and you know as you do when you
start to actually think i'm going to
bring another human into this
world and i it didn't it wasn't i didn't
immediately have flashbacks then it took
a long time i started to get depressed i
started to be very very
incapable of doing very
basic things i couldn't engage with
other people i got really skinny i
didn't i was stopped eating i it was
just i was in this very very dark place
but it was i didn't i know why
and then i then realized i had sort of i
gave myself
i kind of
didn't know why i knew stuff to do with
my dad but i didn't anyway so i kind of
went away and kind of took some time off
and went away i had the luxury to do
that actually it was a luxury to sort of
not not work and go i rented this little
flat i went and lived there for a few
months and it all just was like a it was
like a horror film wow
of you know
going into the
scary forest and waiting for the
showdown with the
the demon and it all just came flooding
back and i was i was in therapy as well
of course at the time and uh
that
and then of course it's so shocking when
it happens because you can't actually
believe it really happened to you right
okay it's like it's like something this
whole new part of you that you didn't
know and then
also then you're ashamed of it as well
you know you realize that you
and also you know i protected my father
as as people who had abused
do good abusers rely on
the abusee being so ashamed
ashamed of what's going on that they
will cover it up and we'll protect the
person who's doing the terrible stuff
it's and you described him as being
charming a charming man yeah he was
charming he was
rachel army very charismatic very sexy
you know he was
uh
yeah and he was about that and you know
and i i
he
you know i i i kind of after my last
because the last thing the the first men
what i wrote
was prompted by the fact that
after not after my brother and i
confronted him and he we didn't see him
for nearly 20 years he came back into my
life
via my brother actually he contacted my
brother and to tell me that i was not
his biological son so the book is called
not my father's son and at the same time
as that i was doing
this uh that bbc show uh
who do you think you are
and i found out that my i and so there's
two stories going at once i find out
that my grandfather my mom's dad
died in malaysia playing russian
roulette none of us
god yes so i have mental illness on both
sides of my family which is just
fantastic
to look forward to so did your mom your
mom must have known that no no no none
of us knew no and i actually i remember
thinking oh this is great my mom never
knew her dad
he she
he died when she was like 13 or
something this would be a lovely thing
to sort of find find it find out what
happened to him you know just find out
the real story
and be a nice my gift to my mom that i
can you know and i just remember
thinking holy [ __ ] this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to me
no i had to call up my mom
oh no and tell her and um
oh no oh it's awful how do you do that
well
is there any lightness is there any
humor in it is it is is it just or is it
totally heavy
well
that was
i mean
the thing about i was speaking to her as
it was all going a lot cause it's kind
of unveiled to you like chronologically
like it isn't sure like when you're
so i knew i mean knew he died in
malaysia
and we knew he died in some it was
always like it was a it was an
accidental
you know it's in a [ __ ] i thought it was
in a shooting range and someone
accidentally shot him my mom then said
oh no he was he was cleaning his gun and
the gun went off and i was like oh
so it's all this thing i never and then
i i thought he'd because he was
in malaysia after the second world war
they hired all these british military
people to kind of be guards for all
these um rubber plantations because
of the communist insurgents
and so they were kind of you know
policing these
places of commerce i suppose anyway he
that's what he was doing so there was
all these people it was a dangerous
thing and lots of people were being
killed and
and i
saw his post mortem and everything it
was really gross and there was a you
know a
bullet wound in the back of his head and
i thought oh he was he was i'd heard
about these killings that i thought he
was killed by these communist insurgents
and then
so i told her that and you know
and then um
and i'd realized that he was obviously
had ptsd and was could not function
outside of the army
uh because he was injured in burma and
oh it was so nice
hunter it was a deer hunter and then of
course i'm finding all that out
and oh god other stuff i find out
there's a park and a street named after
him in this little village in malaysia
that none of us knew about either
so i i what was lovely was about two
years later i took my mom and my brother
there and we and we met these two old
men who knew him when he was a little
boy and everything was wrong oh that's
wild it was it was absolutely one of the
most incredible
sort of things to be able to do i mean
that was the gift for my mom to be able
to see that and see this yeah she didn't
really know him and they loved him so
much they they named this thing after
him but oh wow yeah so but so
at the same this that was all going on
at the same time my father was
saying i wasn't his biological son and i
had to take a dna test and i was his son
uh anyway so fortunately
uh yeah well i of course what he told me
he wasn't and it was so traumatic but i
was like well i'm i'm really glad i'm
not i'm happy yeah and my brother was
saying you're lucky that you're not you
know and then yeah it's probably
up again and then the dna test proved i
was was he equally tough on your your
brother
yes uh but then what happened was my
brother
left home my brother's older than me so
when he left home i was i was alone
and so that was that was the worst those
years were the worst because i was just
it was just me and and uh
you know it reminded me of a little bit
of charlie chaplin's upbringing that
charlie chaplin had a very tough uh
father too and an older brother who left
early family and um and you have a
similar
quality i mean you have his kind of
magical puckishness uh
nice thank you you know it's so weird i
was going to be playing try it was it
was a mini series
i was going to play charlie chaplin i
like it towards and of course his sort
of older drunken years
uh when you just before he did
you know he was like on the scheds and
hadn't made him oh yeah you had made a
talkie
and was kind of you know really like a
sort of
faded start
and then he married eugene o'neill's
daughter yes yes and he did and then he
and then he did um the great dictator he
bounced back with the great dictators
first talkie yeah you know the the
americans
didn't want him to do it the american
government didn't wanted to do it and
then he kind of triumphed again so that
i was going to play him in this thing
and it just never quite came off as
these things sometimes don't so i
studied quite a lot about him
so thank you for saying that i have that
quote oh yeah i think you said
incredible
he's been incredible yeah do you know
what i went on a plane to turkey a few
years ago and there was on the on the
turkish airlines and on the plane they
had these charlie chaplin
a charlie chaplin channel
like just playing charlie chaplin all
the time
and then we got to put uh bucharest and
um
were going around and there's all these
pictures of charlie chaplin everyone's
charlie chaplin cafe and it was sort of
like in the way that we have images of
che guevara or something or you know it
was like an and and our guide guy said
that he
to people in turkey represents like the
little man fighting the corporate
machine oh wow so he's got some symbolic
sort of political
uh nature like in the way she has to us
a rebel you know that's what it was
oh certainly in like modern times or i
mean the way what he taught the class
struggle that he talked about that must
have really resonated with yeah
so it's funny that he's in turkey
no kidding oh interesting well
and alan you must have i mean just in
terms of your father that how much of
that did you channel when you were
playing hamlet i mean that's probably
what well that was also just an obvious
direct no that was also around about
that time
was when i was having trying to be a
father and all that so it was all
happening once so of course hamlet yeah
so hamlet is
someone who
you know is being you know has a i i
sort of thought didn't have a great
relationship with his dad
and then he's now his dad's dead and now
his dad's come back and
you know and his uh it was
it was a lot and also
weirdly and when i played hamlet the
woman who played ophelia was my wife yes
so there was that there was a lot of
stuff going on in that play that was
kind of connected to all the stuff that
i was going
starting to go through in my real life
it was a hot mess the whole thing was
like a graphic story
so in in that way well because you
commit you're such a committed performer
in what way how different then was it to
go to play cabaret to do cabaret to play
the mc
how liberating was that did you find
that and and did that coincide with the
liberation of your own sexuality in your
own life oh well
when i did it in
new york so i did it immediately after
hamlet in london like i was
rehearsing
cabaret in the same theater as i was
performing hamlet in at night
it was just ridiculous and so
i
was kind of more
you know
playing that character i was sort of
basing on
my
you know trying to read and research but
also unlike sort of uh in terms of the
sexuality of it yeah i'd i feel i've
always been
bisexual but i
uh
by the time i came to do it in 1998 i
was actually much more um
what's the word you know i was living
that life in a way i was i was being uh
sexually more
active and was more comfortable with my
sexuality yeah yeah in that way
comfortable
and was your reticence to be open about
it earlier with how much did that have
to do with your parent your father
not so much to do with my father really
but more to do with like i was in when i
was married i was in a straight
relationship that managed yeah uh now
i'm not i'm in a management that's not
straight uh but i was also but i was
also like you know i was i had a
boyfriend before
i got
with the woman who became my wife so it
wasn't she was aware of all that she was
aware of yours yes yes so it wasn't that
wasn't i was sort of outish in that way
that uh but i didn't feel appropriate to
talk about
when i was
married and i guess
you know thing
changes after you get well known when
you people want to know more about you
and also you have a sort of duty i think
to sort of
i mean i felt i had a duty to sort of be
especially with the whole thing of
sexuality when sexuality was
people were you know literally when i
first came to america people were being
killed for being gay uh like like um
matthew shepard that was 1998 that's
where i came in america and um
so
i've
you know that i felt very like oh gosh
i've got to be
people are asking and so i talked about
it more kind of more publicly but i was
always kind of something that i was
people knew about who knew me so it
wasn't and then you know it's funny that
when i got divorced
i don't think i put this in the book but
my wife said said to me oh promise me
the next relationship you have will be
with a man and i was like no i'm not
going to promise that she really wanted
me because i think it would make it
easier it would make it yes in a way i
kind of get it
yeah the narrative of like you know oh
he was scared well he wanted to be yes i
i couldn't provide that yeah and i was
like no i'm not going to promise i'm not
going to be you can't you can't control
me you can't dictate and it turns out it
wasn't
no it was with another woman
so yeah so that kind of confused
everybody
didn't know we actually yeah well was
that ever a concern i mean that was
another really like fearless seeming
thing about you of of the many fearless
uh things you detail in the book that to
me that strikes me as very brave to
um not consider
what people might think what what let's
say casting directors or producers or
people who make those decisions might
think no i didn't really
care you know sometimes i think if you
can play someone convincingly
uh you know there's a whole lot of
hoo-ha
of late about whether
straight actors should play gay
characters
and i just think
straight actors shouldn't play gay
characters if they play them badly
right or unconvincingly and yeah same
with the other way around and i why are
you looking at me alan where are you
but also like i've played lots of
straight people uh you know yeah uh i
don't so i don't uh i play lots of gay
people at all but you know i don't
and i i think i shouldn't play if i'm
not just convincing as a straight man in
the blog yeah i shouldn't play that
in the
obviously outside of that how you live
your life what you do how you express
yourself that's your own thing but your
job is to be convincing it's something
to be convincing as being gay because
this has been australian you know
whatever from another another era and so
i think that
i always
i didn't actually just make that
connection really and also you know when
i first came to america pretty soon
after i came to america and started
working here
cabaret was such a big thing and that
was i was just perceived as this sort of
pansexual little nymph
so i i sort of thought that whatever
people you know i thought it assumed and
i've always been up it's offered lots of
different things and it's true it's like
you've you kind of carved out your own
niche
yes as being like just of an eclectic i
mean that's what i love i think
eclecticism breeds eclecticism and so i
love just the kind of crazy range of and
also now i'm really fascinated by i'm
moving because i'm nearly 60 i'm 56
i think i'm 50 i'm going to be 57 in a
few months and uh so you know it's my
next big birthday is 60. and that to me
is hilarious because i
obviously
i can play like there's a film i'm about
to do and the the you know when you get
the first one you get the script and you
look at the description of the person
and you know i i'm always fascinated by
that it's like how flattering is it
yes yes exactly and this one said uh
blabla early 60s a kind man in his early
60s with thinning hair i was like well i
can do kind
of that's the part i'll dwell on yes
well i love when you it reminds me of
what you said to stanley kubrick which
is also a great part of the book is um
when you did that role it's such an
incredible role and i was in eyes wide
shut where uh you said well stan he was
pissed that you weren't
no you tell the story
yes i've auditioned
uh lots of times for this little part uh
all over the world actually in various
places and it was always you know on
tape and with that or with a producer
never stanley i never met sonny right
and so i finally get the part and i come
on to the set and so it's me tom cruise
and stanley kubrick
and i just bound on
and i'm like hello stanley i'm alan
and he looks at me because
you're not american and i was like i
know
and uh i'm scottish and he goes and he
went you were american on the tape
on the tapes and i i i like i said
inside my head i was like [ __ ] you old
man i haven't auditioned for this
[ __ ] pissy little part it's like six
times
i've waited like six months to do this i
put everything off just to do your
stupid little scene yeah and what comes
out and what i said was he went you're
america on the tapes and i went yeah
that's because i'm an actor stanley
and he and uh
and tom cruise kind of went coughed and
sort of bit like oh you know
yeah and uh and then he and stanley and
he sort of looked at me and can his eyes
smiled twinkled
and he just went let's rehearse and um
and i
we got like a house on fire after that
because i stood up to him i totally yeah
he was being a dick he was like quite
ridiculous to say something you're the
wrong nationality but i
i love those stories i've heard versions
of that story before ellen and i and
you're so it's such a funny part and you
detail it so eloquently like how you
went on to become then have a really
good relationship with him but i i've
heard versions of that story where you
stand up to a bully and they respect you
and yeah
and it's what you did a version of what
you did with your father i suppose and
not that he he now respects you but
there's a but event i mean actually i
think that was you know going and
confronting my dad about the abuse with
my brother
yeah made me like what i was saying you
know it made me very fearless and uh yes
so yes i'd what's that you know that's
what you've got to do you've got to say
to people like what was going to happen
stanley was going to fire me was you
know i mean and also i was like you know
i'm i'm here i deserve to be here yeah
and you're you know you're worth a bit
of a dick right now stanley you know
like saying i'm not
like you know i'm the wrong
aren't you happy that you didn't know i
was scottish that's the whole point i
was acting this thing and being a
different well it's it's brave it's
inspiring to read about and also how you
stood up to brian singer how you set up
to gore vidal the the brian singer thing
is hilarious too because you guys had
that intervention for him yes and when
you were all dressed i just imagined the
sex man it's so easy the more the more i
think about it the more makes me laugh
and just my favorite part is so we're
all in my trailer all dressed as x-men
and
and it's a long story but unexpectedly
they sort of had this intervention dread
all day basically he had been really abu
i mean he had been taking forever not
coming to set and having a clear
substance abuse problem and yes just
making it a very very difficult
environment for everybody yes to work in
and we wanted to sort of
say something and we were going to write
we wanted to do like a joint statement
to the studio to say you know
something needs to be done he needs some
help we or someone needs to come and
help
him work and anyway we were working we
decided to do that and then all of a
sudden brian came into the room so we
had to actually do the
the thing and so harley and i
both said our piece uh and stuff about
yeah we're worried about halle berry how
why did you buy something
and then we finished our thing and
and he was just waiting and it was kind
of you know grinding his teeth and
everything
and all we hear is and alan and harlow
speak for all of us brian and that was
patrick stewart say
suddenly
i'm a cheerleader yeah that
you say patrick stewart for the win yeah
it's patrick's day for the win
it's so good
um
all of us brian so you can't argue with
patrick stewart no you know he's the one
i mean how do you i i want patrick
stewart at every intervention
i mean they can't fail i know i love
patrick's day he's so hilarious i
haven't seen him for a while but i just
always have such a laugh with him oh
alan have you seen the outtakes of
patrick stewart on extras when um
i love how game he is i think i really
love when i see people like that who you
know when i was gonna pee and ian
mckellen and those sorts of people
were
had this big classical careers and then
later in their lives they kind of move
into other areas and then they kind of
lighten up in a way that i just think is
so
exciting and liberating to see
[Music]
hey life is short listeners wonderings
even the rich podcast is doing a
two-part series on the bizarre and
fascinating kidnapping of paddy hurst
and you won't want to miss it
one night in 1974 19 year old college
student patty hearst who happened to be
the heir to the hearst newspaper fortune
was kidnapped from her berkeley
apartment she was kept in a closet for
weeks while her captors made their
demands then after two months in
captivity in a completely unexpected
twist patty announced that her name was
tanya and was seen on video robbing a
bank with her captors the new season of
even the rich explores different
theories about what actually happened to
patty was she brainwashed or was she the
victim of stockholm syndrome listen to
even the rich on apple podcasts amazon
music or you can listen one week early
and add free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app
[Music]
you got to
interact with so many of you talk about
all those those legends who would come
to see you in um when you were being so
celebrated in in cabaret
uh i saw you do i think the second one
the second or
third uh when you came back and i
remember thinking um
i remember getting a little nervous that
you'd pick me from the crowd oh yes when
you pick somebody to dance with because
i'd be like i i remember thinking well
i'd be powerless to to not go yeah you
had such command yes
it is it wasn't really good there was a
part so in the on track
of of cabaret a bit and actually i did i
on my podcast on incoming shelves i had
sam on sam mendes on recently and he was
talking about the fact that he'd said to
me well wouldn't it be funny if when the
orc's just playing in the in the
contract you come out and you take a man
up to dancing a woman up to dance and
just have a little chat with him to get
everyone back into the vibe of you know
the cabaret okay and then in the first
performance he went oh crikey you know
we never never really talked about what
we're going to do what we're going to
say and what that how that and he came
through to the dressing room i never
talk to her oh i'll be fine i've got it
and so i just and that i went on and i
just did it you know and i just
had timed it and i it became a thing i
did every night every time i did i would
get a woman up to dance and get a man up
stance and it would all and it's an
actual a very interesting thing that you
have to be
to you have to sort of be very in
control you have to slightly humiliate
someone without it being too much but
you know you have to
slightly humiliate them but not but also
so that they like it too
yes um it's not you you can't you're not
mean at all but you're going to say
things you have to let them know it's
yours you're you're in control they're
going to be safe but they're going to be
you know ribbed and the pistol is going
to be them a little bit it's a very and
it's a fascinating balance and so i
actually write about in the book when it
didn't work so well yes as if i chose a
famous person because then you know the
balance is and also it's weird like you
know like those when i did it the last
time i remember picking someone up and i
was going in what's your name and they
were like oh i love you in the good wife
and i'm like oh my god the good wife
what is this what do you say to that i
mean i made a joke about it's 1929 what
what's that
and things like that you know it's it
it's sort of one that's just dopey
people but well when i took up mikhail
barishnikov one time and that
it was just incredible i mean it was
it's he it was like
i still think about it like it felt i
really felt like my feet didn't touch
the ground i mean that's such a cliche
but i felt like
oh and it was it was it was
in like his hand in the small of my back
he led like i would always have that
joke i would say i lead and he was like
oh no and uh i i love that did you
actually say that yes like i don't
attempt to delete i attempt to delete
and i would and i would uh and he was
like oh no he did you know oh my god and
then he uh because it was i was i was
trying to say jokes like oh you should
do this for a living you're very good at
all this stuff but it was i just think i
remember it being almost like
um
like i was in a coma or something for a
few seconds
yes i was downstage right the next thing
i was upstaged left and and i i didn't i
didn't know how i got there you know
like a sober blackout
and here you are i mean you're the
epitome of confidence and you have such
command i saw you do the role it's it's
like
it you have such authority and command
and
that's it's interesting to lose that
power then must have been really weird
it was and it was i mean it was
hilarious and of course everyone's just
cheering and it doesn't last very long
that part of the show yeah but i was i
just thought oh it doesn't work when
it's a
famous person and also someone who's
obviously a genius dancer and then the
other time i talk about in the book
walter cronkite night
i didn't i couldn't get a man to come up
this guy i was working on to come up he
wouldn't come and i thought oh [ __ ] so i
i just saw this he had his back to me as
i was walking back towards the stage and
i went come on granddad pulled him up
and then and then everyone started to
cheer the audience went nuts and i
thought i remember thinking oh
americans are so nice to their elderly
they're so loving
and
and i said what's your name cronkite and
i was oh
he was very bit he was tall and very
imposing and he was so lovely but i was
just kind of like oh [ __ ]
what a crunchy bad
i can't believe he did it i can't
believe he went up and was game
yes i know i mean i kind of blindsided
him i kind of came from behind him just
took his hand he didn't really have a
choice
but it was uh and then he um you know i
i forgot actually until i was
researching this book that at the
kennedy center honors a few months later
he actually introduced me
uh at the thing and then i and i saw him
afterwards i was really nervous because
i hadn't seen him since i pulled him up
to dance and he came over to me and i
ran into this room because i was gagging
for a drink was after the show
and
uh
i went to the bar and he was the only
person at the bar and he turned and
walked towards me and he looked really
angry and i thought he was going to give
me you know i i didn't know what to
expect because you know i it was just
sort of one of those things i didn't
really
so many things were happening to me at
the time i didn't really understand
and uh he came over and i thought oh
gosh you know and he went may i have the
pleasure of this dance young man
sweetest thing ever yeah
alan i'm so sorry i i'm seeing that you
might have to go in like five to ten
minutes do i oh yes if i got something
else yeah um okay god so many things
you're a foreskin advocate i want to
talk about that we can't um so many
things
you're right i love what you say about
fooling around fooling around now you
have such an interesting take on the
term fooling around and then making love
you call the pale sickly older brother
of fooling around would you just
describe
uh that
that phrase and what it feels like
fooling around is what american people
say
for any sexual contact you have
up until
penetration of the vagina right or the
anus but i actually think they don't
mean the anus it's mostly a straight
thing i don't know gay people say
fooling around too but they mean up to
yeah up to putting your penis inside the
downstairs bit of someone but it's also
such a cutesy sound it's a very
infantilizing thing chills like yes it's
fooling around and it's all and it's
about so and it means that it doesn't
really matter it hasn't really happened
because it was just floating around you
know we're just footing around even
though
you could ejaculate all over someone you
could both exactly you could you know i
mean there's all sorts of sexual things
that and also yeah by that if if fooling
around isn't really sex
then that means lesbians never have sex
that's
right sure it's quite a big thing when
you think about it and true really
belittling belittling and weird and also
it means that it means it's it means
that it's not worth anything so it
doesn't matter so therefore you so
cheating in a way right is sort of it
diminishes the importance it diminishes
and it also makes it not joyful and it
makes it quite shameful yeah and also
and i've have to say that in my
extensive
sexual engagements with the american
people i made sense i thought oh this is
why you're so
you could do with a bit more force
foreplay skills you know what i mean
because you're straight to the
thing just go right to the end result
you're they're so result oriented
yes it's very well that's america so
everything's a competition yes but i
think it's just very interesting to me
that that the own the word that people
have
that you could you could do many many
sexual things with people i mean i think
if you get naked with someone and you
get hard
and you're doing stuff i think that sex
i've had had sexual relationships i've
had sexual contact with them i've called
that weird music i certainly feel if i
put my penis in someone's mouth or if i
feel like we've had sex
whereas
and so the fact that you don't think
that's
you can say that's just floating around
to me
means that you're missing out on how
good that stuff can be and also you're
kind of
saying it doesn't matter so no it's it's
just it's weird i think it's right and
also you're making it's child-like and
and also like the other thing in in the
same vein as it were is uh that when
people shave their pubes
and like have completely shaped makes it
you look like prepubescent right and i
think why are we trying to have us make
our sexual organs look like children
well maybe it makes it look more
impressive because it's like well if
that belonged to an infant it would be
really like freakishly impressive
i mean i'm all for a bit of manscaping
but to actually go the whole hog i think
it's just really weird um well you talk
about it in the context of the bill
clinton scandal and how he said i did
not have sex with sexual relations uh
and and you then go on to talk about
monica lewinsky and you you how much you
admire her and uh i'm now curious if
you've seen
uh and i don't want to take up too much
time but um if you've seen the the
series that i have been watching it yes
i'm dear friends of monika and she was
you know she was an executive producer
on that and i've talked to her a lot
about it as what's happening and i find
it fascinating i think it's really
interesting to look at that
from the women's points of view and the
sort of motivations that they had for
behaving yeah in the way and for doing
things whatever they did all you know
linda tripp and uh paula jones and and
monica it's it's really fascinating to
me and i just i just you know i think
that
um i actually make an illusion in the
book about why you know both monica and
i
were very defined by our sexuality in
1998 me in a very positive way
and her in a very negative way and i was
being i was promoting and or you know
being sort of the poster boy and
of for
you know
sexual
openness pansexuality and kind of
devious deviousness
uh
or deviance rather and she was and i was
kind of like oh isn't he great isn't he
cookie isn't he sort of
liberating and she was
just a writer derided for yeah just you
know so it's it's it was just an
interesting thing in writing this book
trying to understand why all that had
happened to me i actually
talked about it in terms of what was
going on in the in the country at the
time which was this every night on the
news we saw i know you know fooling
around being completely uh vilified oh
okay alan got it this is too hard for me
to do uh lightning round really quick
what is your most commonly used emoji um
unicorn a unicorn okay that makes sense
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
maybe the high jump
a professional high jumper yeah it's a
very lucrative uh
story if you're gonna be the poor
thought i'd love to be the provo i love
pool vaulting pole vaulting now allen is
not winking or making any sort of
reference to that being a
a sexual metaphor um if you could have
one snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be
um spicy nuts
spicy nuts again not a euphemism there's
no uh
invitation what's your favorite movie
sequ actually if you had kids alan is
there a movie that you would love to
introduce your uh kids or nephews or
whoever it may be well you know spy kids
that i was in yeah i just love the way
that that peop that's changed
the way that i interact with a whole
generation of people because it's a
magical
it's it's it's doesn't age kids still
watch it now yeah and i think kids are
starting to show their kids and it's
actually a really magical thing and i
feel that
i'm very i love the way that young
people come up to me when they see it's
me and they're like you know
ev every day it happens people like mr
flip you know and people say there was
there was a hilarious thing happened
with a boy in albuquerque or a on a film
tv series i was making and a boy came up
to me he was on the crew
and i could tell he wanted to say
something about spike it and he gave up
meanwhile and i just have to tell you
you touched me a lot when i was a little
boy and i was like never say that again
and
take two
yeah yeah yeah
um what is your go-to karaoke song uh
the sun will come out tomorrow oh great
um who was your first celebrity crush
lulu yes singer um if you had to get a
tattoo another tattoo uh what would you
get and and where
and obviously not near your genitals not
anybody's name yes never again um
um
i'm not so sure i might get a i might
get a scottish flag
yeah okay good like a lot of canadian
people always have a maple leaf on their
chest and things yes that's really great
i might get a little might get scottish
flag um what is your favorite fruit
banana
yeah oh that's a great i love that story
too we don't have time to tell it but
people should read the book there's a
really good banana story in the book um
who would you want to play you in your
biopic
uh kate blanchett yes uh and who was
your favorite muppet
um miss piggy
okay yes uh your go-to pizza topping
uh
i just like i like margaret well i mean
i
i like margarita with no cheese
and yeah do you have a favorite beetle
beetles song that you would like to hear
right now if you could play any if
you're in a bar you could go to a
jukebox and hear a beatles song
here there and everywhere i [ __ ] love
that song and there's a great
yes uh emmy lou harris has a great cover
of that too
you're in the market um alan i know you
you have to go i can't thank you enough
uh for this i'm so nice to talk to you
again
i look forward to having a drink next
time i would love that that's all i kept
thinking about reading this book guys
there's because there are too many
things i need to talk about gore vidal
there are too many things i want to talk
to you about
wow so i look forward to it look to be
continued yes thank you my friend
[Music]
[Laughter]
so so that just has happened that's
right
now is why is it not offensive to do
that
that impression
well
it might be it might be it might be i
remember i was sorry oh sorry i was
going to say like some scottish people
that i knew
would get a bit offended not offended
like because scottish people are very
like uh resilient and they take a joke
you know well i was going to be a little
more specific than that but i i agree
what would you say i was going to say
first of all please don't talk like that
the entire time second of all
to answer your
to answer your um queen i guess
rhetorical question
um
about whether or not he'd be offended by
if why that might be offensive or not i
it was a wee bit rhetorical i would say
that
he strikes me as someone who is maybe
incapable of being offended by anything
yes yes least of which is his accent
yeah doesn't he like he might have the
thickest skin of any human being alive
so i certainly don't think he would be
offended that's that's my point and it's
and it's because when you read his book
you you understand like what he dealt
with from his father like he um he gets
into it a little bit in this in the book
baggage but the one before this he um
really unpacks it and i think if you can
get
past something like that and he
confronted his father if you can he says
that this a version of this like he
that's when he's ceased uh being fearful
he he has no fear and i believe him i do
too um it's hard to imagine him ever
being
afraid of anything i know but but when
you come to terms with something as
deeply rooted as that father stuff um
and when you have a father like that and
you have to confront him which he did
that takes true courage i really want to
read that book that's great you'd love
it
having listened to this interview which
i thought he was so fascinating
and told so many great stories that
scratches the surface oh i really want
to read this book yeah yeah you would
love it he's like um
he's like a magical sprite i know
there's something about him that's he's
got whimsy but also he's like he's a
pansexual nymph which is
you know i can say that because he said
that about himself oh that's right
he's pansexual nymph yeah i can see him
he he
like just being kind of loving with an
anybody he's fluid
so fluid yeah remember seeing he's got
real fluid energy we saw him do cabaret
together yes we did remember yeah and
what what do you remember thing remember
when he went to the audience to like yes
take take somebody up to dance with yes
like walter cronkite that's a great
story it's a great story where were you
what was your
feeling when he he started going through
the audience and you you then realize
when anything like that happens to me on
stage even though i'm an actor
there's always a part of me that's like
i get a little like from i remember
being a kid remember we'd go to that
westport country playhouse
they did children's shows and every once
in a while like one of the actress would
bring a kid on stage or like talk to a
kid and i remember getting so
scared that they wouldn't talk to me or
bring me up isn't that weird but this i
mean compared to this though so this
thanks
playing that character sashing through
the crowd looking for someone to bring
up on stage and dance with
i think to answer your question i think
it was the most scared i've ever been in
my life what yeah really because i can't
i remember sweating and like my heart
racing and you talked about it all
because he was close he was like in my
area for a while
yeah i was at at a certain point i
remember being convinced that i was
gonna be the one picking he had also
almost missile locked on to you like he
was like people yes
on broadway
and he this is a character and he has
that character was like there's
something
uh
so
like predatory predatory about that
character yeah and i remember thinking
if he does bring me on stage he can get
me to do
anything yes like he would have complete
control over me and power over me
in part because there's something
extremely charming about him too like
you can't say no to him i think i know
you're saying so are you saying he could
do anything he wants whoa not that he
would but i remember thinking i'd be
powerless i'd be powerless that's
interesting this person but that's an
interesting fear to have that and that
it
not i mean to unpack it a little bit
that it comes down to that to to having
power that he would have power over you
and do anything i mean like if you play
that out play that now i know
but also i was a i thought i would be
humiliated you know because he has this
content yeah and
the person and the character both have
this extraordinary amount of confidence
right
and so he would just
in comparison i would be embarrassed i
would more than embarrassed i would be i
think humiliated because i would not
even come close to be able to match his
i know um self-confidence see my fear
was would be that i would try i'd be i'd
probably be one of those guys that would
like try and he sort of alluded to this
he definitely talks about in the book
how some guys like kind of try to like
match him like i've seen that energy
from guys where they're like yeah you
try to go toe toe no they're not truly
but it's clear they're not as
comfortable and like um
and then that ends up looking even more
humiliating
rather than just like going up there
red-faced and it's an interesting
dynamic to think about it's an
interesting social dynamics like to put
yourself in that position and and what
it says about
is about power and about um
your
insecurities and you know
because you're right i know what you
mean like that character and
and and there's an added component for
me as an actor because like i should
have
i should possess a similar confidence a
stage confidence anyway but like
i remember feeling really nervous too
that he was gonna pick me and like
having
as an audience member there's there's
you know i'd like to think that if i was
on stage with him i would feel confident
yeah but like it to to break that fourth
wall and to like go through that wall
with somebody that like sure of
themselves fearless fearless yeah he is
fearless to be afraid around someone
who's fearless maybe that's what it is i
think that's what it is yeah it's like
oil and water yeah you know
and also there's this sexual component
to it obviously that
he is a pansexual component i mean he's
such a good argument for sexual fluidity
you know i know because i i kind of
associate
not that it's a choice obviously but i
kind of associate his
sexual openness and fluidity with his
fearlessness and openness
and like comfort in who he is and like
really knowing himself
and right to the point where
i it's hard for me to imagine
um there being a better path than than
he's taken in terms of a healthier one
so so then i started thinking well maybe
everyone
like if they really except maybe you
think about it like well maybe i am a
little exactly if you really explore
yourself yeah you think well maybe we're
all kind of capable of that level of
openness maybe it's just about like not
being used to something exactly or
scared it's like what neil would say
neil patrick harris when he was like
you've never
you know done such-and-such he tried to
get really he's a good uh he's a good
case for sexual fluidity too that's
those are
yeah i remember uh doing a play with
alan it was the uh we would do the
24-hour plays and i remember doing this
with him like 20 years ago
i was i have a photo from it i should
post um if i could find it but uh he was
it was one of the first times i remember
like being around a man who who who had
like who was giving me like
kind of
sexual in a very like
innocent way not at all in like a
predatory way but but in but in a
flirtatious way like i was get receiving
like energy from him that's that was
suggestive and like
flirtatious i would say
um and and how did that make you feel um
i mean i was comfortable with it but it
was def it was it was clear it was like
uh i it was and it was i realized it
just wasn't something i was used to even
though
i i spent a lot of time with like gay
men and stuff maybe it was like maybe it
was also that he had this power that he
had like a charm
and so to your point like maybe it
caused me to confront my own
potential fluidity and like
did i just come out uh
maybe maybe i mean you have similar you
have there's something very similar in
my mind between you and alan [ __ ] in
terms of
like you you both have a kind of um
yeah this would be good
you're like there's something kind of
like i i this is going to sound bad this
word
but i mean it in like a cool kind of
open
fluid way there's some kind of like
wormy
about both of you
yeah i do i do kind of know what you
mean
yeah like uh
yeah like
like it's kind of slither like
invertebrate you know like yeah nothing
there's nothing less
yeah no but non like non-rigid yeah
yeah i i uh yeah i i know what you mean
like fluid
comfortable and comfortable
there's something that reminds
me yeah like him of you it's funny like
when when um i i i like it when it comes
to even like it's i remember talking
about doing like a kissing scene with a
man in a movie i i like kissed a man in
a movie i remember people being like
oh that's so
and there was a part of me that when i
was talking about i was like
or after i did it i remember apologizing
to the actor um because he i was sick so
i remember saying he was brandon ralph i
remember saying to brandon rouse like
i'm like i'm sorry about that you know
i'm sorry for kissing you like then he
was like oh no but he was like a little
uncomfortable he was like well those are
the characters i said no no because i'm
sick it hadn't even occurred to me
that it was
weird even though we you and i grew up
in a very we grew up in a very like
traditional
we weren't used to seeing
gay men i mean we just weren't used to
seeing affection between two members
that's different i was used to seeing
gay men i wasn't used to seeing
affection but yeah among them yeah which
is what's nice about like the change in
our culture it's nice that kids are
growing up with like that being
normalized i have two compliments for
you
yes
one
you s very early into the conversation
you said
okay you i i could tell that you glanced
down at a piece of paper and you said
okay so i copied and pasted a bunch of
your quotes here and i thought oh [ __ ]
oh no oh no you're just gonna like
chris farley him
and
and you didn't but you set him up for
some great stories and you i thought it
was really effective
that you read the book learning you
internalized it
and didn't just regurgitate things but
you effectively set him up to tell
you know like small parts of the book oh
orally yeah so i thought that was really
effectively i thought that was really
effective um
and also i admire your restraint not
repeating his accent back at him
no offense i was
quite amazed well
and you had that restraint i feel like i
know how much you like that i do as is
evidenced by the beginning of this
intro it's it's infectious you know what
it is about it it's so like
lyrical there's something about it
that's playful yeah playful but like
sing sony it's got it's why like doing
paul mccartney is my favorite beatle
because he was the one that was oh he
was up and down that he's have a lot
more like lyrical his was or the other
ones like george you know ringo was more
but his was oh he's i i love his voice
so much
but it's because it's closest to that
oh that's scottish you know it's great
you want to read a letter we do it right
wow efficient efficient all right that's
nice and we don't we should have
confidence and it's a great episode oh
great stories stories talk great stories
there's more that means there'll be more
alan in the episode yes
all right here we go
okay all right
okay all right
i'm eating some pomegranate you know i
don't think we've ever had pomegranate
as a favorite fruit
is this your way of extending the
episodes yeah possibly my accent more
okay
from kelsey bennett why am i being like
this why am i so okay because i'm trying
to switch gears i don't want to
oh really that's what that means i think
maybe i don't know what do you think why
is everything all right
from kelsey bennett's subject i missed
the lime skittle flavor
oh i do too yeah
you creeped into that one greek i do too
i gotta oil this chair yeah
well now or just talk about it a lot
right wait dear justin christian and
friends i'm a bit behind in listening to
episodes as i just started listening
from the beginning a few months ago but
reached the aca gonzalez episode today
and absolutely had to weigh in on the
green skittles debate okay
the lime flavor was so much better than
green apple and it is truly tragic that
it has been removed from the mix
couldn't agree more it really i disagree
it messes up the entire valley and they
had a perfect balance those five flavors
in the original skittles perfect back i
don't get why you need a lemon and a
lime perfect belt lemon and limes this
is pretty much the same flavor what when
it comes to like that you just
disqualified yourself from being part of
this conversation lemon and lime you
don't think it's similar enough and then
more similar than the other flavors but
it's not the one it's different
you just don't like the green app you
don't like a green apple
if it was a whole blow pop here's the
thing blue puff
if there's a whole bag if there's a
whole bag of green apple skittles
and someone offered me that bag
i might not turn it down
my issue isn't with that flavor as much
as it is
the combination how it fits in with
we've gotten into this it's the way we
eat skittles is like you eat them
a bunch at a time
i alternate sometimes i do flavor by
flavor i do
i do least to best i do least favorite
tomatoes i'm saying you're doing one
flavor at a time you're not pouring a
bunch of different flavors you're not
invading your mouth with like sometimes
i am oh really sometimes i just i just
pour a little handful and see how they
mix how they mix and the green app but i
don't do that anymore with the green
apple mixes poorly with mixes poorly why
it's overpowering
uh kind of it's just it messes up the
perfect balance it's too it stands out
too much you know it's like to me it's
like putting tabasco sauce on scrambled
eggs oh huh
it's just it it's too loud
yeah i don't like to mess with flavors i
already like so if you are also so used
to that balance i mean that's the other
thing you grew up with it and skittles
were your favorite it's true i can't
separate my experience but i still
prefer the balance well kelsey agrees
back to kelsey i've never before
encountered anyone who cared as much
about this or honestly seem to care at
all but it is a hill i would die on and
i get very fired up on this topic the
green apple flavor feels completely
random given the mix of other flavors in
the pack unlike the lime which fits so
well i couldn't agree more yeah i was so
glad you're arguing the right side of
this
though sorry that justin and anyone else
who believes green apple is better well
that's okay i mean i i would die on this
hill too yeah
i wouldn't
also i thoroughly appreciated hearing
the order in which you each eat skittles
flavors as it made me so happy to hear
others having a conversation i have had
loads of times
additionally i once heard of finding
your skittles soulmate i.e the person
who eats skittles in the exact opposite
order as hue so that in theory you could
split a pack of skittles and both eat
your favorite flavors that's funny i've
yet to find my own she says i've yet to
find my own skittles soul mate
my skittles order from what flavor i eat
first the last is green
okay first the last wow green is wow
that's crazy green's her favorite
how do you know it's her favorite she
says from what flavor i would i eat
first to last doesn't mean it's her
favorite i eat my least favorite first
oh yeah
my skittles order from what flavor i eat
first to last you're right she doesn't
say my favorite my uh is green yellow
orange red purple i suspect that red and
purple are her favorite i do too
because they're you're more commonly
people's favorites but i'm very
supportive of the concept and love
talking about it whenever the topic of
skittles comes up thank you for bringing
such an important issue as the loss of
the lime skittle to light big fan of the
podcast and your acting performances
thanks ah that's nice of you kelsey
thank you
thanks so much kelsey b from
massachusetts all right she gets it she
gets a friend
she's from mass she's getting it yeah
she's from mass one one night our
our one friend from massachusetts said
that about kier our other friend from
massachusetts kia gets it he's from mass
he gets it so now anyone from
massachusetts we say uh they get it yup
um anyway thanks kelsey and and uh here
here here here bring back la we should
start a petition bring back lime skittle
yeah you think that would catch on it
could
that's true but i could obviously i'm
being like super arrogant about my
position on this but i've heard a lot of
people say they prefer green apple well
maybe they oh you have yeah yeah i just
don't it's taste yeah i i suspect well
you know maybe other people can wait i
do like green apple flavor i like that
flavor but you think in this case it
throws off the balance i do um well
thank you to everybody well tell us how
you feel if you want to write in about
any skittles flavor i wonder what alan
[ __ ] thinks you know what i bet i
don't know but he likes them all yeah
all that they're so they're all so good
like them all yeah
it would be a very alan coming thing to
like to be open to all the skittles yeah
and i never i i'm not gonna discriminate
from one skittle to another i like this
they're all so good try not to eat as
much sugar because i'm trying to
maintain my my package frame
you're good at that yeah i like it i
love hearing him talk i love talking to
him it's such a treat to enjoy the like
substance of what somebody's saying yeah
and the way they're saying it and i
think it's fair to say that if there was
ever someone who would be
serve as an entree into the world of
bisexuality he would be that for you
he'd be a great emcee yes for that world
if
true
all right let me and gentle and like you
know
you go at your own pace when you start
off you don't have to do it all at the
same time it's something for you to be
open to something for you to consider i
what does it mean if i'm open to the uh
the consideration of it
um that might mean you're i
curious i guess so but i don't buy
curious is like a an accepted thing see
and i don't want to say the reasons why
i'm not i don't think i qualify as that
because i don't want to be offensive
right and i don't want to
it's just i
i don't know that i describe myself very
simply i would say
the the main reason that neither of us
would describe ourselves as bisexual is
because we haven't had a sexual
experience with a man
right yeah well that's so like the proof
is for the pudding that's true we're
met we're i didn't we met in our 40s and
we've only had experiences with one
thing so
doesn't that give you some indication
what our sexuality is
isn't it likely that this is the way
it's going to be now right at 43 years
old you kind of know we're not 15.
that's true and we live in a very open
culture and we know allen cummings so
like if we were to explore that
it probably would have been probably and
not to say that alan would have been
open to it i'm not saying like you would
have it's arrogant of me to suggest but
i remember us having a really good
connection with
at the same time i think it's okay to
say never say never that's true you know
universally when you know alan [ __ ]
you know
um
anyway thank you to alan and uh god what
what an enjoyable person to talk to i
just and his book again uh please pick
it up it's called baggage
and it is so good if you enjoyed that at
all i can't wait to read that oh you'll
love it to kelsey for writing in yes and
for having the correct skittles opinion
and if you guys would like to write in
our email addresses life is short at
wondering.com so thank you all and thank
you to alan and everyone oh the scottish
people and uh and if i offended any of
you with my impression please forgive me
it's it's all it's purely
out of affection
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long is co-hosted and produced by you
geelong it's also produced by megan v
monaco and ktv alan senior producers
michelle miche lance and the audio
engineer is sergio enriquez executive
producer is
marshall louie and all of it is for this
wonderful company
that's gone wondering wondering all
right sorry bye bye
[Music]
glitter is the worst
i hate it because i love the way it
looks
i really like the way it looks it tricks
you into like
it makes you like the the looks of it so
much
to the point where you buy a product
that has it on it and then you're stuck
with it
and you can't get over your hands if
you're trying to get glitter off your
body it's impossible it's impossible
it's impossible
watch the meatloaf it's impossible
soap and water doesn't do it
it's crazy have you tried
[Music]
decades
you